welcome back to Las Vegas now how many
virtual celebrations have you had since
the pandemic I've had a few virtual
talent shows virtual house parties but
there are also ways to celebrate in
person while social distancing we wanted
to give you some tips from an expert on
how to do all of this the right way and
the most festive way so welcome to the
show Michelle hi thank you so much for
having me thank you you look great out
there look at those balloons I can't
wait to see them all but tell us first
and foremost here about your business
balloons with a twist sure I started
this company about 26 years ago and we
are a premier entertainment and event
planning company and we specialize in
out-of-the-box balloon decor and
deliveries love it and of course you
know parties are looking a little
different now because of kovat 19 so
what are some ways or suggestions that
you are changes in servicing excuse me
that you guys have made in your company
and that you guys are given your cut
dear clients well I think at first
people were a little unaware of how to
celebrate but you know birthdays are
happening graduations lots of
graduations and so we were trying to
think of ways to help people celebrate
but remain socially distant and safe so
we did a lot of drive-through parades so
we can make balloon arches for
drive-throughs and then we can decorate
garages and front doors and cars for
parades as well as lawn art and Conflict
contact list deliveries so we've tweaked
we've pivoted a little bit but we
continue to celebrate and I'm sure
people want to want to have celebrations
so business should be good right now
even though we've had to make those
changes right yeah absolutely people
want to normalize for the children
especially birthdays so we're finding
ways to to change things a little bit
remain safe but still be able to enjoy
celebrations absolutely so what are some
suggestions you have for people who want
to host these parties so I think a
combination of a virtual party and a
drive-through celebration is the best so
basically you send out an evite or a
Facebook invite and you let people know
when the parade is maybe if there's
seem and then the children that are
invited can make a poster celebrating
the birthday child or the person that's
having a celebration and then they drive
through it a specific time wave they may
be they have balloons with them and
posters and then what I've seen the moms
do that works really well is have a
couple of tables at the front of the
driveway so the first table can be to
drop off gifts and the second table can
be to pick up maybe a goodie bag or some
fun snacks so then when the family
leaves they go home and then the virtual
party starts and everybody can be
invited maybe thirty minutes an hour
after the parade and then the child can
open the balloons and then you know sing
happy birthday and everybody can still
be a part of the party but but remain
safe I love that you just got to make it
work right yeah a hundred percent and I
understand you have something called air
hugs that people can be involved in to
explain those well one of the things
that I miss most is hugging people I am
definitely a hugger yeah so one of the
things I thought it was an air hug and
basically it's a little balloon guy with
balloon arms and we can deliver them
contact list delivery right to your door
just to let somebody know you're
thinking about them and that you want to
give them a hug we and thoughtful that's
so sweet and thoughtful and I understand
you guys have a special contest going on
for viewers and for people out there
that includes a social distance party to
your door
yes it's called party to your door I
really wanted to do something to give
back to the people in our community
there's so many amazing essential
workers health care heroes and just
everyday people that are going over and
beyond right now in during this pandemic
so I contacted some of my friends that
owned businesses and they all said yes
right away and basically we're giving
away a party to your door every week
until the end of July and you can enter
on our website through our website on
our Instagram or a Facebook and you can
nominate yourself if you like or you can
nominate somebody that's deserving
and basically just anyone that you think
would deserve a party to your door and
it includes popcorn from popcorn girl
and bananas from Lee Elena's bananas and
flowers from flora Couture cupcakes from
rolling in dough bakery pizza from
Grimaldi's and of course balloons
alright it's thank you so much I hate to
cut you off and have so much fun but you
look great I love those balloons and we
will see you at the party
thank you see